let's take a quick look at some blunders
that people regularly make in dealing
with asymptotic notation in particularly
with Big O notation which tends to
confuse people so the most important
thing to remember is that this notation
something equals o of something else 1
over x equals o of 1 say is actually to
be understood as just a not such
attractive notation misleading notation
for a binary relation between two
functions this is supposed to be a
function there and there's supposed to
be a function there and this is saying
that the there's a relation between the
growth rates of these two functions o of
F is not quantity and you mustn't treat
it as such so for example and the
Equality of course is not an equality
once upon a time we tried to get the
Equality replaced by an epsilon which
makes much better sense that is that
membership symbol but there was a sense
that this notation was so deeply
embedded in the mathematical culture
multiple mathematical communities that
there was no way we're going to change
it okay in particular a confusion with
where you think that that equality sign
means some kind of inequality is to
write instead of f equals o of G well if
F equals o of G by symmetry o of G or to
equal f don't write that the reason is
that it's a recipe for confusion because
look at this I know that X is o affects
trivially which would suggest that o of
X is equal to X if you believe in
symmetry and you think of all of X as
being quantity well remember though that
2 X is also equal to O of X by
definition of all so what we wind up
with is combining 2 x equals o of x with
o of x equals x is I get 2x is equal to
this thing is equal to X I conclude that
2x is equal to X which is absurd so
that's nonsense it's the kind of trouble
that you can get into if you start
thinking of this equality as meaning
equality between two quantities as
opposed to just being a part of the name
of a relation
another mistake that people make it's
less serious but it's sloppy is to think
that Big O corresponds to a lower bound
so that people will say things like F is
at least oh of N squared
well again at least of N squared is
starting to treat o of N squared like a
quantity you could say that F is equal
to o of N squared but that means that N
squared is an upper bound on F to within
a constant factor after a certain point
if you want to say intuitively that that
N squared is a lower bound on F then all
you have to do is say that N squared is
o of F and that is a proper use of O of
F of getting a lower bound on a function
by saying that the lower bound is o of
the function that's another example of
the kind of nonsense that you say this
is a stretch but let's look at it as a
reminder of things not to do
I'm gonna prove to you that the sum from
I equals 1 to N of I that is that 1 plus
2 Plus 3 up to n is of n now of course
it's not we know that the sum of the
first n integers is n times n plus 1
over 2 which is o of N squared theta of
N squared actually so I'm gonna prove
something false watch carefully how I do
it here's the false proof let's first of
all notice that any constant is o of 1
so 0 is o of 1 1 is o of 1 2 is o of 1
and so on any constant is any constant
function is o of the constant function 1
ok that's true so that means that each I
in this sum is a number so that means
it's you know it might be 1 in my 2 it
might be 3 you might be 50 whatever it
is it's o of 1 and that means that I
could think of this sum from I equals 1
to N is o of 1 plus o of 1 plus o of 1
and that's of course n times o of 1
which is oh of n now there's all kinds
of weird arithmetic rules and things
being used here none of which are
justified but you it's just a heads up
you do see stuff like this from
inexperienced students
I hope that you won't fall into this
kind of a sloppy trap all of something
is not a quantity it's part of the name
of a relation